donc c'est évidemment transpartisan
c'est à dire qu'on est tous les tous les
tous les groupes de de du Sénat peuvent
être représentés bien sûr ou sont
représentés et notre notre audition
d'aujourd'hui fera l'objet d'un
compte-rendu et d'une retransmission
donc
Hervé on devrait finir enfin tu devrais
finir en fait parce que le gros du
boulot c'est lui qui le fait
fin juin début juillet à peu près c'est
ça
par rapport évidemment qui
contiendra notre analyse de la politique
de l'aube les dans notre pays et des
propositions surtout c'est ça qui est
important pour l'améliorer parce qu'il y
a sûrement des améliorations à faire
tenant compte de tous les avis qu'on
aura entendu alors dans le domaine de
l'eau les départements le passé pour le
savoir
jouer historiquement un rôle important
en matière
mais le retrait de la clause de
compétences générale évidemment les
amènent à devoir revoir leur stratégie
en même temps le président de la
République en présentant le plan o leur
demande de piloter l'ingénierie
territoriale de l'eau alors faudrait que
le Président de la République sera
proche de Marylise le bronchus comme ça
il pourrait peut-être s'entendre puisque
c'était la loi nôtre qui nous avait
retiré la compétence générale mais en
tous les cas les départements ont encore
leur rôle à jouer là-dedans et c'est
dans ce cadre là que vous êtes invité
aujourd'hui donc on souhaite entendre
la vie d'abord d'une élue départementale
mais qui représente aussi
l'Assemblée des départements de France
EDF
et connaître un peu vos
souhaits d'évolution législatives si
vous en avez et vous en avez j'en doute
pas et vous avez et pouvoir échanger sur
la base du questionnaire que vous avez
que vous avez reçu donc je passe
immédiatement la parole à
Hervé gilet notre notre rapporteur et
bien merci monsieur le Président Charles
je remercie également mes collègues
d'être présent on est dans un format
malheureusement au niveau de la
temporalité un peu contenue parce qu'on
a les questions gouvernement qui
démarrent à 15h donc on va essayer si
vous le voulez bien peut-être d'aller à
l'essentiel sur les sujets les plus
saillants que vous souhaitez mettre en
perspective dans le cadre effectivement
de nos travaux on a tous conscience que
malheureusement la conjoncture mais pas
uniquement nous permet en même temps au
sens noble du terme de politiser un peu
plus le sujet ce qui est plutôt
intéressant et que par rapport aux
différents travaux aux différentes
annonces notamment du président de la
République
du jeu c'est aussi d'approfondir
certains sujets et de voir aussi
concrètement comment ils peuvent
s'incarner aussi dans les territoires
parce que certains d'entre eux sont plus
complexes qu'il n'y paraît comme la
tarification différenciée par exemple
qui est un sujet qui est assez délicat
malgré tout donc le questionnaire que
nous avons transmis à plusieurs grands
champs et peut-être d'abord vos
réactions de manière plus générale sur
votre vision sur la mise en oeuvre
aujourd'hui des politiques de l'eau
justement effectivement sur la la place
des départements ou parfois le retrait
de certains d'entre eux ce qui a pu
inquiéter d'ailleurs des agences de
l'eau quand on les interroge aussi sur
sur ce sujet là peut-être que vous avez
quelques messages à nous faire passer
d'ailleurs sur les gouvernances au
niveau des bassins des comités de
bassins et votre approche effectivement
territoriale à ce niveau là et puis sans
aucun doute dans cette première partie
vous avez sans doute aussi un niveau
d'analyse sur les rapports de force qui
commence à
se mettre en perspective sur plusieurs
territoires on en connaît certains qui
ont été très médiatiques mais au-delà de
cela on voit bien que la ressource en
eau aujourd'hui
nécessite aussi des coopérations
territoriales quand on voit que beaucoup
de métropoles vont chercher leur eau sur
le reste des départements ça veut dire
que comment on le fait et sur quel
principe de coopération territoriale
alors peut-être ce premier chapeau déjà
madame la Présidente si vous voulez bien
réagir en vous remerciant de votre
disponibilité
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs c'est un honneur pour moi en
effet de porter la voix au nom de
l'Association des départements de France
et vous imaginez bien que au nom du
département ça doit vous rappeler en
effet quelques événements
malheureusement médiatique puisque
sainte Soline se trouve dans les
Deux-Sèvres et que évidemment le sujet
de la gestion durable de l'eau à un écho
tout particulier pour moi en tant que
présidente de département
je pense d'ailleurs avoir été choisi
aussi pour pouvoir porter cette parole
vous l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur
c'est un sujet éminemment politique au
sens noble du terme c'est à dire que
c'est un enjeu de demain nous en avons
conscience au sein des départements et
nous avons encore et plus que jamais
notre rôle à jouer dans dans ces
politiques publiques
le département pour nous à deux rôles
essentiels
le premier déroule c'est d'assurer
justement la quantité et la qualité des
eaux notamment brutes à tous les acteurs
du petit cycle de l'eau il faut que
chacun vous l'avez un petit peu énoncé
dans les questions qui allaient venir
mais globalement il faut que chacun
garde son périmètre il y a les acteurs
du grand cycle de l'eau que sont les
agences de l'eau et les départements
mais le petit cycle de l'eau lui a
d'autres responsabilités c'est de
mailler le territoire communal notamment
sur les réseaux d'eau potable
d'assainissement pourquoi pas également
de production mais chacun doit avoir son
rôle chacun doit avoir son périmètre et
ses compétences et le deuxième rôle du
département et c'est son rôle de
fédérateur de territoire j'ai envie de
dire c'est d'en réguler les usages
nous sommes certains que les
départements sont la strat
idéal pour justement réguler les trois
grands usages qui sont donc l'eau
potable les usages économiques et le
soutien à l'étage ce n'est pas la taille
d'une EPCI puisque les EPCI vous savez
tous dans vos territoires ne sont pas
forcément la le périmètre des bassins
versants donc quand on a plusieurs
bassin versants et bien il est essentiel
qu'on est une strat qui permette de
couvrir l'ensemble de ce bassin versant
et souvent c'est le département
pour je serai quelques transgressions
pour le département par le département
des Deux-Sèvres parce que on a quand
même des sujets haut notamment le marais
poitevin également je peux vous assurer
que déjà sur le marais poitevin c'est
trois départements qu'il le gèrent
environ 21 structures publiques par un
public s'il fallait choisir de réguler
les usages de l'eau avec les 21 et ben
déjà à trois c'est très compliqué
alors parce que les priorités ne sont
pas toujours les mêmes même si nous
entendons très bien et nous le devons et
bien 21 pour prendre des décisions c'est
compliqué donc voilà deux rôles majeurs
quantité qualité pour les acteurs du
petit cycle de l'eau et régulation à
travers la mixité des usages
justement le marais poitevin mais il y a
pas un syndicat mixte qui porte
justement ces politiques avec l'ensemble
des collectivités qui sont adhérentes il
y a pas de syndicat mixtes sur la sève
niortaise on a un epmp c'est ça
il y a eu une étude justement sur le PTB
et donc le résultat de l'étude c'est
bien que le PMP reste
la structure la plus adéquate dans la
gestion et satisfait les différents
acteurs mais il y a une multitude de
strates sur le marais poitevin qui est
qui complexifie en effet donc il faut
simplifier les choses chaque compétence
chaque périmètre
on a huit thématiques on a environ 8
syndicats que ce soit sur le la
production le traitement ou la
distributeur
on a 7 à 8 syndicats par thématique
traitement distribution ou
il y a pas un syndicat départemental
vous avez ok tout l'intérêt des
départements dans une relation aussi
d'accompagnement et de proximité
pour approfondir cette question de la
gouvernance territoriale les régions
aujourd'hui
montent un peu plus en puissance sur le
sujet des politiques de l'eau
elle participe bien sûr au niveau des
grands bassin versants également à
l'orientation de de ces politiques elles
peuvent avoir un atout c'est le fait
d'avoir la compétence aussi économique
au-delà aussi
d'une vision de planification
territoriale par le biais d'estradettes
qui quelque part aussi accompagne les
planifications au niveau des territoires
une des orientations cette consolider
également la vision des politiques de
l'eau dans les Scott et dans les pluies
ça fait partie de d'un sujet que nous
travaillons aujourd'hui parce que ça
nous semble pertinent d'inscrire la
gestion de la ressource eau et pas
exclusivement aussi dans les documents
d'urbanisme aujourd'hui
comment voyez-vous éventuellement cette
affirmation peut-être des compétences
aussi régionales sur ces sujets là et
notamment l'accompagnement des filières
professionnelles
on va dire dans l'évolution des process
process de sobriété etc pour le coup les
régions ont quand même des compétences
spécifiques après ça interroge la
relation région département dans un
cadre de complémentarité
oui alors je crois qu'il y a aussi une
hétérogénéité au niveau des régions
quand on est dans une région comme la
nouvelle Aquitaine comment vous dire que
c'est quand même compliqué d'avoir des
politiques communes entre les deux
sèvres les Pyrénées les Pyrénées ou la
partie de Limoges ou encore la Gironde
je vais être très franche avec vous
puisque nous sommes entre nous et que le
but c'est bien d'avoir le retour terrain
nous ne sommes pas associés au
stradettes
très clairement de temps en temps vient
nous dire tiens qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez honnêtement c'est du pipeau il y
a pas on
intervient pas on n'a pas on a nous ne
sommes pas acteurs du stradette donc je
vais mettre de côté la région par contre
ce qui est intéressant quand même sur la
région et sur la gestion durable de
l'eau c'est son rôle vous l'avez dit sur
l'économie j'ai envie d'aller un petit
peu plus loin sur l'économie agricole
puisque elle dépend sur donc la PAC
voilà
alors sur le côté agricole nous notre
lien il est fort puisque c'est sur ce
cet
usage là qu'on va aller chercher
notamment la qualité de l'eau et là
aussi le département a des outils
d'ailleurs formidables que ce soit
l'aménagement foncier qui nous permet de
protéger des zones de captage on a bien
évidemment le travail que nous
effectuons sur les ENS ou sur les zones
les zones humides donc il y a on a on
intervient sur j'ai envie de dire une
compétence qui qui est partagée malgré
tout partager c'est c'est l'agriculture
le lien avec la région je
pourrai alors personnellement elle se
résume à peu près à ça dans la gestion
durable de l'eau
oui oui j'assume parfaitement mes propos
je me suis Roussé sera ravi de 20 ans de
mais je le dis aussi devant lui donc il
y a pas de il y a pas de souci pardon
non non mais je enfin on travaille sur
plein d'autres choses avec la région
mais sur la politique de l'eau
je pense que c'est plutôt l'orientation
agricole et je peux je peux pas vous
dire ce qui est pas vrai non plus
la boîte à outils entre guillemets
départementales et encore assez
satisfaisant pour accompagner ces
politiques sur le territoire
départemental
parce que quand on questionnait la perte
de la clause générale où il y a la
compétence solidarité territoriale qui
permet aussi peut-être un certain moment
d'accompagner certaines politiques plus
ce que vous avez pu citer sur les
espaces naturels le foncier etc donc
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous souhaiteriez
vous qui est une nouvelle évolution ou
est-ce que la situation actuelle vous
satisfait
je crois que chacun doit surtout prendre
ses compétences où elles sont
le département à ce rôle un petit peu
d'amont du petit cycle de l'eau je crois
qu'il doit être en pleine compétence sur
ce sur ce sujet là ce qui ne l'empêche
pas par la suite sur justement les
communes ou les syndicats de communes
aujourd'hui
c'est plutôt comme ça que c'est
constitué d'aller accompagner que ça
soit en ingénierie technique par des
agences d'ingénierie par exemple ou même
sur des investissements des
co-financement sur des équipements mais
je crois qu'il faut il faut pas
disperser les compétences de chacun
et de vouloir aller tout financer ou
intervenir surtout je crois qu'il faut
que chacun se limite justement dans ces
dans son rôle et dans son périmètre qui
est le sien
on peut peut-être pour clôturer
juste ce chapitre là on a une petite
difficulté pour évaluer en fait le
positionnement globalement des
collectivités départementales certains
agences nous indiquaient que des
départements avaient tendance plutôt à
se retirer de des actions qui pouvaient
avoir
sur ces sujets là d'autres avaient tenu
malgré tout aller maintenir est-ce que
vous au niveau de l'ADN vous avez une
vision un peu plus globale un peu plus
précise
nous la volonté enfin de je vois que
Monsieur Guillot est arrivé mais la
volonté de DF et d'ailleurs dans dans
l'amendement qu'il propose c'est bien en
effet la possibilité d'exercer la
maîtrise d'ouvrage des travaux que ce
soit en production d'eau potable
création et puis l'aménagement des
réserves d'eau le périmètre en fait que
j'ai défini tout à l'heure
l'interconnexion des réseaux c'est la
position d'EDF de pouvoir intervenir sur
l'émission et le rôle des départements
pas forcément dans le réseau d'eau
potable de la commune c'est pas le enfin
c'est pas le rôle de des départements on
a des enjeux appartements interviennent
aussi sur les stations d'épuration oui
sur l'assainissement mais on parle
d'ailleurs beaucoup des eaux usées et du
retraitement des eaux usées forcément
parce qu'après ça repart dans le grand
cycle de l'eau donc c'est quelque chose
qui nous intéresse c'est du
co-financement mais la maîtrise
d'ouvrage elle est elle est communale ou
à syndicat de communes quoi oui bien sûr
mais
accompagner par solidarité territoriale
bien évidemment notamment en termes de
financement
qui reste d'importance effectivement
aujourd'hui c'est certain
après la taxe départementale des espaces
naturels sensibles ou la taxe
d'aménagement aujourd'hui mobilisée
aussi en partie parfois sur ces
politiques là c'est le cas
nous pour le département c'est 100% de
la taxe d'aménagement sur les ENS et sur
toute la protection des captages des
zones de captage
tout à fait donc plutôt orienter qualité
de l'eau alors vous citez votre exemple
du coup sur la protection des zones de
captage c'est un sujet qui évidemment
est questionné aujourd'hui avec
vraisemblablement une augmentation du
nombre de zones de captage à protéger et
prioritaire par rapport à la
problématique des pollutions diffuses
qui montent en puissance de plus en plus
ce qui questionne aussi sur ma
multiplier les protections de zone de
captage ça veut dire aussi comment on
finance les services rendus à un moment
donné par le monde agricole puisque il
va forcément devoir faire évoluer ces
process dans ce cas de figure est-ce que
ce sont des des sujets que vous avez pu
aborder
c'est c'est justement l'enjeu de la
transition agricole
moins d'un an
des cultures qui sont moins demandeuses
en eau et en parallèle
cette enfin je me permets mais je crois
que la volonté du monde agricole c'est
d'aller dans le sens également de la
protection de l'environnement la terre
est pourrue leur outil mais il faut pas
croire que on continuera à cultiver
sans eau on aura toujours besoin d'eau
pour notre agriculture par contre c'est
comment on l'utilise et comment on la
ramène finalement dans dans
l'environnement donc sur les zones de
protection de de captage on a par
exemple donc je parlais de l'outil de
l'aménagement foncier mais toute la
partie avec les bouts environnementaux
qui fonctionnent quand même très bien
qui est un outil performant et qui nous
permet vraiment
améliorer sur ces zones de captage à
travers de la prairie à travers à
travers des dispositifs de plantations
de haie
du maraîchage bien évidemment
ça permet justement de protéger nos
zones de captage et là on est bien dans
le rôle du département
de veiller à la qualité de l'eau c'est
l'échelle départementale et la strate
qui qui est la bonne pour celle-ci il
existe au sein d'EDF ou des groupes de
travail spécifiques un peu sur ces
sujets là
il y a un groupe de travail eau et
biodiversité au sein de DF
l'important c'est vous soyez là
peut-être juste pour clôturer ce passage
et donc dans ce cas de figure vous avez
aussi parlé de l'intérêt de développer
les interconnexions bien sûr et de
d'accompagner aussi les collectivités
dans ce cas de figure j'ai cité des
exemples aujourd'hui qui questionnent de
plus en plus sur les coopérations
territoriales entre agglomération
métropoles et restent du territoire
c'est un sujet aussi qui monte en
puissance aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
un sujet qui a été travaillé également
au sein de l'ADN ou sur lequel vous êtes
un peu sensible parce que derrière ça
veut dire pour faire court aller
chercher de l'eau ailleurs questionne
forcément les compensations ou les
négociations de coopération
territoriales qu'il faut mettre sur la
table
alors je sais pas vous pouvez peut-être
répondre sur DF mais
la présidente alors oui sur les
coopérations territoriales c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on est encore à un stade
où on est sur une clarification des
compétences et parfois des explications
au niveau local entre les collectivités
départementales et par exemple les
métropoles donc c'est vrai que pour
l'instant en termes de coopération je
pourrais pas forcément vous en dire
davantage ou en tout cas étayer mon
propos avec des exemples extrêmement
probants voilà
très bien alors nous on a quelques
exemples qui commencent à être
assez
prégnant
sur la Gironde par exemple vous avez sur
la métropole de la Gironde un principe
d'aller chercher l'eau dans le Médoc
alors actuelle sur des champs captant et
qui questionnent beaucoup les
coopérations territoriales effectivement
dans dans ce cas de figure Président je
vous laisse peut-être le soin de moi on
va mais c'est la parole à nos collègues
Florence c'était dans les
starting-blocks tout de suite donc tu
peux y aller le rendre Patrick merci
président merci à vous pour ces éléments
je voulais peut-être un complément sur
la question de la protection des
capitales avec les bons environnementaux
parce que j'ai l'impression que dans mon
territoire c'est assez peu développé
donc est-ce que vous avez des données
sur le voilà le développement des bons
mais environnementaux et
comment est-ce que vous quel type de
captage sur les quel type de captage les
départements interviennent et comment
sur leur protection par à part les bons
environnementaux est-ce que vous pouvez
un petit peu nous dire quel pourcentage
des captages est-ce que c'est que les
captages prioritaires est-ce que vous
allez au-delà et sur quels critères
alors j'ai pas de chiffres à l'échelle
nationale
du coup je vais me permettre de prendre
plutôt le cas des des Deux-Sèvres nous
avons deux retenues donc de barrage sur
le département les bassins enfin le
bassin versant si qui va vers nos
retenues bien évidemment on est en bout
environnementaux
alors sur notre département on n'a pas
de la profonde en fait donc on est
obligé de faire de la retenue en eau à
ciel ouvert ce qu'on appelle en ciel
ouvert donc barrage ou retenu de
substitution mais c'est vraiment sur les
baux environnementaux je sais pas sur
les Mac là ce qu'on appelle les MAEC
mais je sais pas nationalement nous on
fait beaucoup beaucoup de
d'acquisition foncière enfin dès qu'on
peut on fait de l'acquisition foncière
pour
accroître la qualité de l'eau sur le sud
de notre département on est impacté par
les pesticides on a des taux à certains
endroits assez forts voilà donc mais sur
la qualité c'est vraiment un sujet et ça
passe par ça passe par là
l'état de la législation sur la question
des droits de préemption vous semble
suffisante
alors oui puisque on a on a un droit de
préemption sur la SAFER donc ça nous
permet ça nous permet en fait d'obtenir
satisfaction sur cet outil là
même si nous travaillons en amont avec
la SAFER pour éviter d'avoir notamment
sur des transmissions d'exploitation
agricoles sur par exemple sans hectare
s'il y en a 40 qui sont en zone de
captage et 60 voilà qu'on ait un
agriculteur qui soit d'ores et déjà
engagé dans des beaux environnementaux
pour pas le priver après de 40 hectares
alors que lui a repris pour son hectare
voilà donc on travaille avec la SAFER on
fait un travail en amont avec la SAFER
ça se passe très bien je suis désolé de
prendre l'exemple des Deux-Sèvres mais
c'est celui que je connais le mieux
c'est c'est donc ça permet en effet de
de pouvoir
de pouvoir présenter et de s'assurer de
s'assurer de la qualité de l'eau par la
suite de captage à l'heure actuelle
on est à 3% de la surface agricole
utilisée au niveau national c'est pour
mesurer un peu l'enjeu donc si on
mettait en place des zones de protection
voilà un petit peu près à peu près
l'enjeu mais du coup la question du
financement des services rendus
est une question vraiment importante et
intéressante voilà elle questionne même
indirectement la PAC quand on y va un
peu plus loin d'ailleurs sa question
aussi un peu ces sujets
Eric tu voulais parler rapidement une
petite question là
lors des annonces du plan haut on a vu
que les départements peuvent se voir
confier la maîtrise d'ouvrages délégués
en matière d'eau potable sur la mise en
oeuvre notamment des schémas
départemental départementaux de l'eau
alors l'ADF c'est félicité de ces
annonces alors je suis pas certain
d'avoir bien compris les réponses vous
allez apporter aux rapporteur mais
est-ce que vous pouvez nous faire part
des exemples qui donneraient du crédit
justement à ces possibilités nouvelles
pour les conseils départementaux
alors le schéma départemental enfin les
schémas départementaux d'ailleurs de
l'eau sont
initiés par les départements en général
c'est quand même c'est quand même les
départements qui qui les initient
l'avantage aussi sur sur la strate
départementale c'est que on a la même
strat administrative que l'État qui
donne les autorisations de prélèvement
donc sur le schéma de l'eau notamment
sur l'usage économique c'est vrai que ça
permet de donner une cohérence dans les
politiques les politiques de l'eau alors
je sais pas où j'ai été imprécise je
suis désolée tout simplement que lorsque
vous faites un schéma lorsque vous
faites des travaux d'interconnexion
lorsque vous avez des syndicats
primaires qui n'ont pas la capacité
financière à exercer ça veut dire est-ce
que vous pouvez
vous substituer au syndicat primaire
c'est bien ça j'ai bien compris et puis
il faut il faut qu'on garde cette
compétence elle importante parce que en
effet vous l'avez dit l'investissement
est tel ces images je vais reprendre
l'exemple des deux cernes nous avons
deux barrages à 50 km l'un de l'autre il
y a que notre département qui est en
capacité financière de les
interconnecter et aujourd'hui on parlait
de coopération territoriale aujourd'hui
on doit être en capacité
d'interconnecter au maximum
les eaux brutes l'accès à l'eau brut
pour sécuriser l'accès à l'eau
juridiquement vous pouvez le faire ah
oui enfin nous on a interconnecté il y a
très peu de temps
dans les deux barrages on a
interconnecté en 2015 ou 2016 donc
c'était après la loi neutre enfin ça
doit tomber je sais pas si ça a été
commencé avant la loi neutre c'est en
même temps mais ce qu'il y a derrière la
question c'est pour bien effectivement
clarifier regardez les champs du
possible par rapport à ça mais
l'amendement qui est proposé par DF
justement c'est pour nous mesurer que ça
soit bien écrit dans le texte et c'est
pour ça que l'amendement que DF propose
est important parce que même si nous le
pouvons aujourd'hui il est il est quand
même préférable que ce soit écrit dans
le prochain texte en effet donc même si
nous le pouvons il est important de le
réécrire et seul aujourd'hui la strate
du département est en capacité
d'interconnecter
oui oui bien sûr
je peux vous lire exactement mot pour
vos mots si vous le souhaitez
on va regarder ces sujets là d'un peu
plus près parce que les sujets
d'interconnexion sont effectivement
importants donc dans ce cas de figure
c'est loin d'être négligeable à ce sujet
donc si on glisse un petit peu plus sur
l'organisation
territoriale
donc c'est vrai que les schémas
départemental taux pardon il y a intérêt
ce qui est une déclinaison dans les
scruter dans les pays quelque part on
est bien d'accord
ce côté pluie on a sans doute un souhait
d'affirmer donc cette gestion notamment
du fil de l'eau dans le cadre des pluies
sur le pluvial qui est aujourd'hui
parfois et pas très bien géré si vous me
permettez l'expression au sens
environnemental du terme et territorial
du terme donc il y a un vrai sujet vous
pouvez peut-être réagir sur ces sujets
là quel est votre vision aujourd'hui de
la mise en place de la de la loi nôtre
sur l'intégration au niveau des
communautés de communes on sait que
c'est un sujet qui est évidemment
particulièrement sensible mais quand on
l'approche on s'aperçoit qu'il y a du
plus et du moins de chaque côté aussi
c'est pas aussi un blanc et noir qu'on
pourrait qu'on pourrait le dire que la
notion de différenciation territoriale
peut peut-être avoir du sens aussi mais
c'est aussi une vraie une vraie question
d'organisation spatiale aujourd'hui et
puis on voit bien quand même que
si certains petits syndicats peuvent
avoir beaucoup de vertus n'en demeure
pas moins qu'aujourd'hui ceux qui sont
directement impactés par le manque de
moyens et de capacité pour faire face
aux enjeux de demain et qui sont déjà en
difficulté c'est souvent les toutes
petites structures quel est votre point
de vue quel est votre niveau d'analyse
alors sur sur
le transfert de compétences
communales vers l'intercommunalité ce
n'est pas EDF de juger bon
ouais vous voyez je voulais être aussi
franche que parfois je peux mettre un
petit Joker en effet non non c'est
vraiment je pense que c'est lié au
territoire c'est lié déjà aux
compétences que le PCI a déjà nous ce
qu'on constate c'est que le PCI est en
train de plutôt de retransférer des
compétences communales
les syndicats de communes permettent
plutôt une bonne efficience fin de ce
que je peux constater personnellement
je voulais j'avais un argument sur sur
le les syndicats mais comme nous sur les
fuites
nous avons 8 PCI et nous avons 8
syndicats d'eau en fait c'est à peu près
à la même échelle que le PCI mais c'est
pas le PCI qu'il porte ce qu'on sait
c'est que les communes ne peuvent pas
porter seul un investissement d'une
usine de potabilisation ou voilà enfin
je parle pour les territoires ruraux
parce que il y a aussi une grande
différence entre les métropoles de
Gironde et les territoires ruraux donc
il est difficile de de pouvoir donner un
avis général
national surtout que sur les réseaux
d'eau potable il y a une différence
entre les territoires ruraux ou en effet
on a beaucoup de canalisations pour peu
d'habitants alors que sur le sur le
secteur de des villes ça facilite par
contre il y a un principe quand même
c'est l'eau paie l'eau
voilà c'est je crois que c'est le fameux
principe donc il est surtout important
de travailler ça dans le cadre des
annonces qui ont été faites j'imagine
que la DF va être très attentif aux
évolutions donc vous avez vu qu'il y a
un chantier de de rénovation je sais pas
si on peut utiliser ce terme des
redevances qui est posée au niveau du
Conseil national de l'eau à l'heure
actuelle les 475 millions annoncés
seront de toute façon financées par une
augmentation de la redevance
donc sur ces annonces du plan haut sur
les moyens alloués aux agences de l'eau
est-ce que vous avez aussi donc une
opinion des avis particuliers
on se réjouit de l'augmentation des
plafonds évidemment
plafond
est-ce qu'on est bien sûr que les
plafonds de sautent pas ils augmentent
on est bien d'accord
alors on verra au niveau de la loi de
finance mais justement comment tout ça
va se transcrire mais il y a encore il y
a encore voilà quelques encore bellement
si vous me permettez l'expression
quelques incertitudes qu'il méritent
d'être clarifié voilà mais je vous ai
interrompu
après c'est plutôt l'Agence de l'Eau et
le lien avec l'ofb sur lequel DF est
particulièrement vigilance qu'on parlait
des fuites dans le réseau il faudrait
pas qu'il y ait des fuites dans le
circuit financier donc il faut quand
même
être attentif et que l'eau paye l'eau ne
doit pas payer l'eau et la biodiversité
comment se paye la biodiversité et bien
la biodiversité doit se payer par la
biodiversité justement et c'est à dire
la taxe d'aménagement est faite pour
protéger la biodiversité qui
naturellement va protéger l'eau ça c'est
aussi un principe de financement à un
moment donné qu'en pensez-vous puisque
pour le coup même sur les pollutions
diffuses aujourd'hui le traitement de la
pollution repose que sur les
collectivités publiques pour faire court
donc ce qui serait pas judicieux et plus
vertueux qui est aussi un partage au
moins dans un premier temps et une
participation aussi des produits ou des
producteurs de produits qui sont aux
sources de pollution
alors tous les tous les producteurs
parce qu'il faut pas il faut pas
forcément concentrer le côté pollueur
chez les agriculteurs nous avons aussi
voilà l'industriel voilà mais c'est vrai
que souvent on parle de pollueur on
pense
des producteurs des produits donc
exactement je crois que il y a un grand
plan de sobriété qui est annoncé et ça
c'est essentiel il faut aussi un plan
sur la sensibilisation à notre
environnement c'est ce qui améliorera la
qualité de l'eau et c'est ce qui nous
permettra d'engager aussi moins de frais
pour le traitement de l'eau parce que
aujourd'hui le traitement de l'eau le
coût du traitement de l'eau est
important donc c'est forcément dans
l'intérêt de chacun je crois que ce soit
le monde agricole le monde industriel ce
sont des mondes économiques qui qui font
des vrais progrès alors peut-être pas
assez rapide et c'est jamais assez
rapide on voudrait toujours que ça soit
ça soit plus mais je crois qu'il y a des
vrais progrès parce que ils ont compris
que demain si on veut avoir l'eau
nécessaire à leur propre usage
économique et bien il doit faire ils
doivent préserver l'environnement donc
c'est l'intérêt de chacun et je crois
que c'est un grand sujet
sociétal qui forcément concerne un
moment donné les pouvoirs publics mais
c'est l'intérêt de chacun et le devoir
de chacun d'ailleurs
alors il y avait un rapport de nos
collègues au niveau de la délégation
introspective je sais pas si vous en
avez vu connaissance par rapport à ça
justement sur sur ces sujets là avec une
proposition de création d'une ressource
spéciale affectée aux agences de l'eau
consistant une taxe complémentaire à la
part des départementales actuelles sur
la taxe d'aménagement
donc si je comprends bien vos propos
vous n'y êtes pas favorable non on est
bien d'accord je vous l'avais bien
compris monsieur le rapporteur
il est question aussi de voir sur
certains ouvrages ou certains projets on
a vu la au travers du plan haut comment
les agences de l'eau pourraient se
remobiliser sur un certain nombre de
sujets avec les emblèmes afférentes il
est question aussi peut-être de regarder
quels sont les chantiers nationaux qui
pourraient être aussi être financés dans
ce cadre là parce que il nécessite sans
doute une mutualisation à la fois
d'ingénierie de connaissance au niveau
national voire même il peut y avoir des
projets d'investissement qui
mériteraient plutôt d'être mutualisé au
niveau national comment voyez-vous cette
perspective prenons l'exemple de la
tarification différenciée dans sa mise
en oeuvre aujourd'hui c'est un chantier
qui va être commun sur l'ensemble du
territoire national il est très complexe
et parfois législatif sur le partage des
données par exemple donc c'est pour nous
c'est sans doute par exemple un sujet
qui devrait être mutualisé pour
conscience collective et regarder
comment les bonnes pratiques peuvent se
mettre en place sur les territoires
pour répondre à essayer de répondre en
tout cas à votre première partie de
questions je crois que la politique de
l'eau est une politique décentralisée
et elle doit le rester
je crois que la gestion de l'eau au plus
près des territoires elle est importante
alors avec l'agence de l'eau
les relations sont partenariales et ça
enfin ça se passe ça se passe plutôt
bien je pense sur tous les territoires
je regarde DF mais surtout les
territoires de France ça se passe bien
parce que il y a une vraie implication
sur le territoire alors je ne connais
pas je vous avoue les un exemple de
projet qui pourrait être national mais
cette politique de la gestion de l'eau
doit rester je crois pas qu'elle doit
être nationale
c'est pour ça que j'ai essayé de
répondre à votre question
nous nous sommes bien dans un principe
de confortation par bassin versant et
son bassin versant d'une gouvernance
territoriale il y a aucun souci mais
certains sujets mériteraient d'être
mutualisés au niveau national voire même
d'avoir des enveloppes qui leur sont
délégués parce que ce sont des chantiers
nationaux et il peut y avoir
éventuellement aussi des projets
nationaux à ce niveau là de la même
façon que la recherche fondamentale et
la recherche appliquée quand on y
regarde un peu plus près c'est pas
toujours très lisible pour voir comment
ça peut être mobilisé souvent la
recherche dépend de la recherche et
développement des grands opérateurs donc
il y a aussi des sujets de voir comment
on mutualise un peu les moyens on
améliore la mise en lisibilité des
moyens voire sous forme aussi d'appel à
projet par exemple pour accompagner les
nouveaux process industriels agricoles
il y a aussi des questions de fonds qui
se posent de ce côté-là comment être le
plus efficace possible et ce qui est des
effets leviers avec l'Europe vous voyez
c'est aussi un peu ces questions tout ce
qui peut nous permettre d'A vous aurez
la gestion de l'eau doit l'être que en
effet que ça soit national ou
territorial sur les grandes les grandes
mesures sur l'innovation le retraitement
des eaux usées aussi c'est une politique
en effet qui qui peut qui peut être
national
enfin je vais répéter mais c'est
vraiment l'intérêt de chacun et en même
temps l'intérêt de tous pour pour aller
vers une gestion du moment que la
gouvernance en effet reste par reste
vraiment impliqué sur le territoire il y
a pas de souci là-dessus mais après on a
des grands bassin versants qui sont un
peu plus dynamiques fiscalement que
d'autres et donc c'est aussi la
perquation des moyens un terme à ça
voilà pose sa question là qui sont
posées
est-ce qu'il y a des collègues qui
souhaitent aussi bien
oui bonjour à tous excusez-moi pour le
retard j'espère que ma question n'a pas
déjà été abordée mais on a reçu hier en
audition un représentant de la Cour des
comptes qui nous parlait du
désengagement de bon nombre de
départements compte tenu du contexte
économique compliqué j'aurais aimé
connaître enfin savoir si vous aviez une
connaissance de l'ampleur de ce
désengagement
je vais me retourner pour la question
parce que ça a été un petit peu abordé
en effet tout à l'heure
DF au niveau national parce que je alors
nous on note pas un désengagement
particulier des départements sur la
question de l'eau s'il y a bien un sujet
qui fait quand même presque peut-être
des exceptions que je ne connais pas
mais en tout cas ne se voit pas c'est
uneanimité ou une quasi uneanimité sur
la question sur la volonté de continuer
à s'engager donc là via l'amendement
subsidiarité des groupements de
collectivités compétents dans le cadre
de l'eau et la gestion de l'eau et de
l'assainissement mais toutes les
départements à ce jour continuent d'être
mobilisé donc moi est-ce que vous auriez
la les moyens de nous faire une petite
note très éclairante sur le sujet si
jamais vous avez aussi les données là
sur les moyens qui sont alloués
aujourd'hui par les départements sur les
différentes politiques qui sont menées
ça permettra d'y voir clair au travers
des différentes auditions qu'on a pu
avoir que ce soit au niveau des agences
vous voyez la Cour des comptes même les
agences nous ont fait remonter un niveau
d'inquiétude sur le sujet d'engagement
des départements donc c'est un sujet
qu'il faut clarifier il faut
l'objectiver si vous pouvez
d'enquête sur différents sujets alors
peut-être que certains départements
attendent aussi les évolutions
législatives qui viendraient sécuriser
juridiquement leur intervention d'où la
nécessité de cette amendement en tout
cas en terme de mobilisation des forces
et en termes d'intérêt pour la question
de la gestion de l'eau je pense qu'on
aime je parle sous la l'autorité de
madame la Présidente mais les
départements sont totalement impliqués
et ça de façon unanime peut-être de
manière un peu plus précise pour revenir
sur ce sujet
je suis dans un syndicat des eaux qui
est sur deux départements la finance
apporte 20% de subventions sur les
projets de renouvellement et l'autre
n'intervient pas du tout donc voilà
c'est pour avoir les éléments là combien
de départements interviennent notamment
sur l'investissement et accompagne les
collectivités voilà pour savoir si c'est
majoritaire ou
c'est vrai que pour discuter quand même
régulièrement de ce sujet là
c'est vraiment un sujet d'actualité
enfin ça n'a jamais été aussi autant
d'actualité et je sens pas un
désintérêt ou
non prise de conscience du sujet de
l'eau chez mes collègues après en effet
sur des co-financement on est sur la
solidarité territoriale les politiques
d'intervention auprès des syndicats
communaux sont libres de toute
gouvernance départementale
et avec avec des priorités qui sont
données nous on a trois interventions
financières qui sont recentrés justement
sur
l'assainissement mais on vient pas sur
les réseaux de d'eau potable par exemple
c'est vraiment un choix de gouvernance
je pense que DF a un travail alors
extraordinaire à faire mais alors c'est
très très très
hétérogène sur le sujet
je crois que les départements ont
toujours marqué leur intérêt pour la
gestion de l'eau
le problème aujourd'hui c'est en plus
c'est un périmètre tout à fait pertinent
au moment des laboration par les préfets
des ptg-e complètement mais ceci étant
dit les départements qui le soulignent
en raison c'est que financièrement ils
ne sont plus dans la situation qui était
la leur il y a quelques années
aujourd'hui ne lève plus l'impôt ils
n'ont que des recettes qui sont
totalement aléatoires c'est pas vous que
je vais le dire avec les DMTO et la
dotation de l'État qui voudra bien nous
arriver à la hauteur que nous ne
maîtrisons pas donc je comprends qu'il
puisse y avoir des départements inquiets
mais c'est vrai que ce qu'on constate en
plus dans nos départements c'est des
choses qui sont pas organisées si vous
voulez on a sur nos départements on peut
avoir un syndicat départemental qui
réunit quelques communes et pas toutes
on peut avoir des syndicats de communes
qui sont encore tout seul on peut avoir
un département qui s'investit mais à une
échelle un peu différente d'un autre à
côté c'est c'est quand même complexe et
ça mériterait d'être clarifié voilà avec
une organisation très en silo les stages
les stages les les ou finalement même
mon préféré avec qui j'ai discuté il y a
pas longtemps sur l'élaboration des
ptgen me dit mais même moi j'ai du mal à
comprendre toute cette organisation
désolé mais c'est vrai
bien évidemment je ne peux pas aller à
l'encontre de vos propos concernant les
finances des départements mais
ceci dit
l'eau doit être une priorité pour les
départements et je crois que l'ensemble
des présidents on parlait de
transpartisans je crois que le sujet est
transpartisant aussi au niveau des
départements ça doit être ça doit être
vraiment un sujet essentiel pour nos
gestion de politique publique par contre
si on se recentre sur notre rôle notre
mission que j'ai pu que j'ai pu dire
tout à l'heure le stockage la production
la sécurisation et bien si nos crédits
nous les concentrons sur nos compétences
et notre périmètre et bien ça peut nous
permettre d'agir c'est pour ça que j'ai
commencé mon propos en disant
chacun sa mission chacun sa compétences
chacun son périmètre pour que les
financements soient le plus efficient
possible et qu'on sache où on va plutôt
que d'aller s'éparpiller partout
soyons dans dans nos objectifs et dans
notre rôle surtout et notre strat
géographique
de question
chers collègues
non donc je le reporter oui justement la
conclusion ma collègue évoquée
effectivement les sages aujourd'hui
dans les différentes annonces
ce sont les schémas qui sont un peu mis
en avant même si là où il y a une
éventuelle difficulté ou peut-être pas
un intérêt flagrant
il y a une nouvelle proposition
aujourd'hui qui est mise sur la table
sur le fait de mettre en place des clés
à ce moment-là qu'on pourrait dire des
clés de préfiguration qui pourrait être
moins contraignante mais qui permettrait
de réunir l'ensemble des acteurs sur les
territoires dans le cadre d'un ptgo ou
pas d'ailleurs dans ce cas de figure ça
pourrait être une bonne solution pour
accompagner également
la montée en conscience collective sur
des sous bassins donc qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez effectivement
sur ces sujets là sachant que dans une
planification idéale EPTB
cedage EPTB sage et page c'est
effectivement pertinent mais
parfois ce sont des documents lourds
longs à élaborés
et voilà c'est la complexité parfois
interroge sur leur efficacité et si les
collectivités je terminerai là-dessus si
les collectivités territoriales viennent
pas en appui des agences de l'eau pour
financer les plans d'action souvent les
plans d'action reste un peu l'être morte
je réitère mes propos le département est
une strate importante dans la
gouvernance et dans la gestion durable
de l'eau ce qui est important sur nos
territoires c'est d'avoir le bon outil
de concertation mais c'est pas la
concertation qui fait la maîtrise
d'ouvrage vous parliez de le PTB le PTB
il planifie il ne réalise pas les
travaux donc c'est avoir une gouvernance
de concertation ah oui
c'est possible quoi c'est possible c'est
possible mais voilà c'est pas c'est pas
la généralité je pense mais c'est
vraiment cette concertation et après à
chaque collectivité là encore selon son
périmètre d'intervenir dans la
réalisation des travaux mais mais l'eau
on est tous concernés enfin ça s'arrête
pas ça commence pas à un endroit ça
s'arrête pas à un autre on a décidé que
ça s'arrêtait enfin les conséquences des
enfin les actions des uns
les actions ont une conséquence sur sur
les autres donc c'est vraiment cette
concertation qui est d'une évidence pour
là encore être efficient dans les
investissements on peut plus permettre
d'investir dans dans des plans d'actions
qui montrent ses limites en fonction de
la nature des territoires et des cours
d'eau à protéger on parle de la Gemma pi
la protection des inondations dans
certains endroits malgré la fiscalité
j'ai ma piste c'est impossible de
pouvoir financer des systèmes
d'endiguement et de référence compte
tenu de la nature des coûts et le fait
que l'État ne peut intervenir
n'intervient qu'au maximum qu'à 40%.
s'il y a pas un appui extérieur des
collectivités territoriales les
territoires définissent des systèmes de
référence et d'endiguement
[Musique]
et on voit les sujets qui émergent de
plus en plus à ce niveau là
plus le coup de financement de toutes
les études etc qui reste un peu en
suspens parce que
c'est partagé
depuis une autre question mes collègues
est-ce que vous auriez un dernier
message à nous faire passer peut-être
important je veux juste vous remercier
de d'attacher autant d'importance en
effet à ce sujet et je peux malgré le
sentiment qui peut être
qu'on a pu entendre sur le désengagement
des départements je veux réaffirmer tout
l'intérêt je en tout cas de DF ça c'est
sûr mais de la majorité de la grande
majorité des départements d'être acteur
on s'interroge simplement je pense que
globalement de tous autour de la table
on est plutôt intéressé quand solidarité
les départements jouent vraiment leur
rôle je parle bien en subsidiarité en
complémentarité je crois qu'il y a aussi
une organisation affirmée aujourd'hui
mais on a besoin d'objectiver le sujet
voilà d'y voir un peu plus clair au
travers des remontées qu'on a pu avoir
voilà à votre bénéfice je peux me
permettre ce que je veux dire
[Musique]
merci beaucoup voilà bah écoutez merci
monsieur le rapporteur merci mes chers
collègues merci à Coralie merci
son DGS merci à la DF souhaitez à la
fois présidente de des Deux-Sèvres et
vice-présidente de l'EDF en charge de
ces dossiers là
à des porte-paroles oui bon
exécutif dans tous les cas merci à vous
et c'était important qu'on ait la voix
des départements
et nous sommes tous très attachés au
département en Espagne mes chers
collègues
voilà